300 families over 1 000 authors are
going to benefit please help me reach my
target now
yes that's correct not only does it
encourage you to read it tells you how
many verses you've read how many pages
you read how long you've been on it and
best of all the hasanah counter download
the qurani app now and have a ramadan
with allah's book like you've never had
before
we have what's your name june june
that's good june we're in september
yeah i'm good man that's good
june yes
i think maybe you're the first person
ever that i'm talking to that is a satan
worshiper
tell me the story
um i was christian for two years okay
when i was 18. okay um i found out about
it from my ex who was a witch at the
time pagan she's a witch pagan yeah um
she used to be a satanist okay so i
found out through her
and the more i discovered the further i
went into it i've been to the temples in
america
just works
it works yeah
okay so when you say it works what do
you mean by that
works for my life gives me freedom be
who i want do i want within reason
and still have a good afterlife
okay who promised you after that for me
he promised you
and why do you know what he said is the
truth
in alice the crowley is the book of law
yeah he is said that the hierarchy of
demons cannot overrank another demon
so what he says as the ruler of hell
it's true i'm gonna go to surah ibrahim
so we can make some sense of this yeah
yeah so now you're a satan worshiper so
you worship satan to an extent okay why
do you worship satan is he deserving of
worship
so we worship baphomet yeah we say hell
satan at the end okay who's buffalo nick
father is above satan he's above satan
and who is he we call him iblis sorry we
call him iblis
we have iblees and we have his foot
soldiers yeah yeah okay so is baphomet
the
iblis
i guess sorry okay why is he deserving
of worship
he promised you he promises you good
afterlife okay good afternoon peace
so how is he well when you talk about
satanism or satan we're not really
talking about someone that's quite good
here yeah so how have you defined that
as someone good okay
so satanism comes from two words
satan and ism they both derive from
latin okay
which means opposition
and isms opposition yeah and ism comes
from ismail which means um god
so it's the opposition to god
okay how could opposition to god be good
so god is good we don't deny that we
follow the bible's timelines aka adam
and eve jesus christ
but we don't follow his outlook on life
in our doctrine he does say a lot about
the bible and what you should follow
yeah but for example it says
you can't have sex before marriage right
yes or you can't be gay yeah we don't
follow those stuff
what
we just don't it's not in our doctor so
you're rebellions yeah so if you're
rebellion against god which is the
ultimate source of all creation and the
creator of
it
yeah he created
he was always there so is he good
okay so god is has you affirmed god
what's the attributes of god does he
have a beginning
no all powerful knowing
i know it doesn't make sense logically
in a broad understanding of it yeah it's
outside of human comprehension
so if you're putting too
all-powerful against each other you
won't know the outcome until judgement
day no but the thing is here under
judgement day what's going to happen is
uh which i'll show you but guess what
satan says next one that you worship and
satan will say when the matter will have
been decided so he's going hell is clear
he's going to paradise is clear right
it will be said allah promised you a
cheerful promise while i gave you a
promise and did not fulfill it so satan
is promising you a lie and on the day of
judgment when you're with him he's gonna
say this this is what's gonna say to you
he's gonna say god promised you a
truthful promise well i gave you a
promise and i did not fulfill it i had
no influence over you except that i
invited you and you accepted my call so
do not blame me but blame yourself
neither i am to come to your health nor
can you come to my health i disown your
association with me associating me with
allah in the past surely there is a
painful punishment for the undress so
satan is saying
i like you
you followed me because they're coming
to you more powerful number one even
though it's contradictory because allah
says in the quran if there was more than
one god they would fight each other yeah
so the fact that you are following satan
and you know that god is the most
powerful they can't be too powerful god
ultimately has to create can i yes so
what you're saying is from the quran yes
we don't follow the quran and also we
don't worship satan so we worship
and you're saying that two old powerfuls
come together it contradicts yes it
doesn't it does it's on judgement day
you'll see what happens
in the bible what is hell described as
oh
i don't know a lake of fire it's one
sentence in the whole thing yeah why
would he not describe all of it well it
does in the quran that's why i believe
the bible has been corrupted where does
it say that the bible is itself
the bible the scholars of the bible
itself is corrupted
and the quran says go to those who
change the scriptures with their own
hands and say this is from god forget
what muslims say go to the bible
yourself okay but what you're doing now
is you're worshiping something that's
not deserving of worship and not only
that huh how is he not deserving it's
not just worship because there's
something more powerful than him
which is god yes of course baphomet that
you're talking about is not deserving of
worship because something created him no
one created him my friend no no he did
god is uncreated you can't have to
uncreate uncreated beans
sorry yes you can
do you know what kantos are okay
no okay so you know in islam you have
hadiths yes
satanism kanto they are poems made after
dante's death okay so dante in one says
although there may be two more powerful
deities than myself yeah there is one
worthy of worship
okay so this okay so there's two powers
what about one worthy of worship so what
scholars have decided from that is that
dante believed that although there were
two more powerful gods that would fight
on judgment day
there is something that created them
which is outside of comprehension and
that's the only line in the counter that
says that so if there's too powerful and
one is worthy of worship
our point still stands because even if
satan we believe satan has embraced our
certain powers that's given to him by
god we believe the antichrist will have
some powers that's given to him by god
my friend satan is not far from that no
no i know but baphomet
has certain powers that's given to him
we refer to him as iblis yes yeah it
believes has powers that is given to him
why is it by a god
because he said to god give me until the
day of judgment and i will misguide them
yes so what you're doing international
is you're rejecting god because god
always do something so you're taking
your logic over god's commandment and
that's the reason why it believes
baphomet got misguided
because god
is satan
no at least no satan
we use that interchangeably but
is the main guy he's the one who
disobeyed and this all started and then
he has his children
little satans you know etc they can't
you know whisper the specific satan when
you're praying the spiritual satan that
tells you to do this and that so here's
a little for soldiers the point i'm
trying to make here is that when god
almighty told him to bow down to adam he
said no and why did he say no because he
used his logic his
logic over the knuckle which is god's
text that's what caught him to be
misguided and that's the reason why what
you're following is you're outright
saying here we believe there's god but
we don't follow him yes so why are you
why are you doing that because you're
using your logic and your logic is
misguiding you not only that you're
worshipping something
but it's not deserving of worship i
believe
it yeah what you've um told me
we already believe so we know that god
created satan gave him certain powers
and then kicked me down to the lake of
fire no no did he create baphomet
nah that's the issue here we say that he
did pray how could you have two powerful
beings how does it save affirmative in
your
quran because one you're talking about
the head it has to be a police
satan is not met my friend they're two
different people in police i'm saying
baphomet has to be obliged if he's the
main source i'm saying from our
traditions
he has to be able if he's the one yeah
do you worship
yes so his ignorance
my friend
from your quran you only believe one
satan right no no one there's iblees
and there is many of for soldiers
so you believe that there's a belief
right yes so
what you're saying is just going back to
the quran if you go back to old
doctrines and scriptures yes there's two
they're two distinct different beings so
like you're saying you've got iglys
yeah but why are you worshiping him when
he's a source of evil father is not the
source of evil he is okay my friend
satan is the source of evil right
okay okay so satan we do we don't
worship
even though it's called satanism i told
you why it's called satanism okay
opposition of god
baphomet
is the counterpart of god but he is
described as the god of peace and he
gives you peace in the afterlife one
second
this uh
let's draw him
is it like this something like this yeah
something like that yeah
and then you have
god yes
and then you have satan yes
yeah
you worship
baphomet yes
satan is
now
he was created by god
tell me the attributes of baphomet tell
me start talking about
attributes as in powers or looks
looks powers tell me about it
so he's depicted as a goat
with a human body he's got tears and a
penis okay okay so here's the image of
duality
and his attributes he has the exact same
attributes as well
can you tell me how he can be god that
has two boobs and a penis and his gut
head is a goal can you tell me how on
earth does that
even resonate with an all-knowing
all-powerful god a god of mercy and
justice so that's just what he's
depicted as so if you're putting it that
way why is he depicted in that way why
not another way okay
he's depicted as the image of duality so
duality coming from a man a man and a
woman and then a goats are animal woman
man all three in one
okay but how how can i relate that and
say that is god worthy of worship
so he promised you a good afterlife if
you just follow him and follow his moral
outlook on life
so if you worship him what would you get
in the afternoon
so you know how in islam you have seven
levels of jenna
there's more than that okay oh yeah but
to my understanding
in um
satanism from dante's inferno and the
paradisio purgatorio all that he wrote
there's nine different levels of hell
okay seven of them continue in torture
till you get to the bottom
yeah so you're judged on your sins the
top two
paradise you have whatever you want now
i usually analogize it like this right
so if you believe that you can sell your
soul to the devil yeah and get whatever
you want on earth yes
then if you go into hell which is ruled
over by batman he could give you
whatever you want in the first two
levels
so in hell you get whatever you want in
the first few levels
you're in the fire
there's no fire now we're gonna ask for
water
can i water please it's hellfire there's
no fire now no you said this in the
first two levels
what's the paradise
you said the other three are paradise
top two the top two are paradise seven
torture oh okay
so one second you said that you if you
this if you obey him yeah
you get paradise yeah well to me you're
explaining god you're just giving you
hold it back from there you call it
worship all you've done is [ __ ] it's
idolatry you said i'm gonna call not in
god i'm going to call him baphomet and
then
i'm going to follow him and worship him
and then there's also god in the picture
so what's the point of god here then
what's god doing here is he just
watching
so
the reason we worship baphomet instead
of god is because he gives us so much
more freedom than what god does
like relating back to the um you know
the sex okay one second one second so
you are basically what allah says in the
quran you are worshiping your desires
so what you're doing you're wealthy
worldly desires yeah yeah
whatever you like desires
yeah yeah this is your good
this here
is your god because what you're saying
is the following
and that's exactly how satan got
misguided i told him to bow down to adam
yeah he said no because i'm better than
him he used his logic which is actually
made him the moment he said he's better
than adam he showed how stupid he is and
how he's not better than adam because he
was arrogant yeah
and he said i'm creating a fire and he's
created of clay
so what he's done is he is acknowledging
or trying to logically say well clay is
better than fire yeah god gave him that
brain or god gave him that
logic how are we using your logic to
attack god what he tells is right what
you're saying is no we don't like what
god said we're going to follow
what we call iblis
something else we're going to follow our
desires he's going to forfeit our
desires i know we'll make an imaginary
person with a goat and boobs and a penis
and we'll call him buffonette and he
tells us
and this is by the way following the
desires because no such thing with
government exists
i believe and what you've done is you
made it up in your head and you're like
okay we'll follow back from there okay
so that's how it seems to me and now
you're following him because he allows
you to do whatever you like and allah
says have you seen the one who takes his
own desires my friend
i've said this multiple times they're
not the same people but satan says
follow your desires
sorry i'm talking about batman i'm
talking about this
yeah although he gives you certain
things you can do
states before marriage being gay and
tranquil
it gives you certain things you can do
that isn't in the bible or the quran
yeah and it's against what god commanded
yes yes so the fact that he's given you
the free will to do that and choose who
you want to be yeah he's wherever your
worship is
whoever you are yeah
he he claims you no what you're doing is
the following you're saying
because he allows me to do things god
has told me not to do is worthy of
worship and you're not sure allah says
have you seen the one who changes
desires his own good the one you're
disobeying because you don't have what
he's saying what's the best for you
don't disobey him because you don't like
what he's saying
if he's deserving of worship just the
way you believe
baphomet is deserving of worship because
it tells you to have some sexual freedom
doesn't mean he's good for example i'll
call this example in the discussion
if you go to a kid and say chocolate or
broccoli
what's wrong with the kitchen
but would chocolate benefit them
no
which one would benefit them
it's the same situation god is telling
you broccoli you're saying i want
chocolate and if you carry on having
chocolate it's going to be bad for you
you know what the amazing thing about
this is
god tells you there is a chocolate you
can have yes just be patient but have it
this way yes today it's shocking
yeah and by the way me talking to you i
had to do my
means my prayer to protect you because
you're saying it's a worshiper i'm not
saying you're bad don't get wrong here
there's hope i'm not trying to say but i
have to protect myself because we
believe in the other realm yeah satan's
jinns yeah
otherwise i will say to you wait i have
to do my prayer what do you practice
like yeah you don't have to say this but
you practice like magic
you said
okay look listen junior look you're a
fellow human being
i'm sorry if i offended you before but
for now
i'm sorry
what i'm trying to say in the following
is i want the best for you like i want
for myself yeah i believe the part
you're on is wrong
but what i'm saying is have you read the
quran you haven't give the quran a
chance
okay let's give you a question
yeah
no problem if you want get my contact
details yeah we can go
but what i'm saying is just think about
it god wants the best for you
having anything you want doesn't
necessarily mean it's good for you there
are certain things that god has greeted
us with you can have marriage you don't
have to have sex before marriage yeah
there is a lot of juices orange juice
apple juice raspberry juice stay away
from alcohol there's a lot of meat
chicken beef duck arguing this
he only gives you what you want to a
certain extent
okay okay that's good now june that's
very interesting yeah even though net is
giving you freedom to a certain extent
then why do you worship the one
giving you more freedom no but one
second what does that mean that's good
dude check this out yeah mathematician
you can do no god is saying you can do a
b but not c d e f g yeah you can do a b
c d e f but not
verse